if you raise poultry you know the value
of quality feed and the importance of
disease prevention during production
harvest transport and storage grain
exposed to moisture can be contaminated
with toxins as byproducts of fungal
growth a prime example is the mycotoxin
aflatoxin aflatoxin molecules accumulate
around moulds growing on feed subsequent
ingestion of these toxic particles can
cause Mico toxicosis resulting in
devastating livestock health problems
and production losses understanding my
co toxicosis begins with following a
mycotoxins journey through the animal's
digestive system digestion starts in the
stomach where gastric juices and
hydrochloric acid release aflatoxin
molecules from the feed and toxins get
dispersed into the digester from there
the toxin molecules move down into the
small intestine along with nutrients the
mycotoxin are absorbed through the
intestinal wall the toxin molecules and
nutrients are carried into the blood
where they are metabolized by the liver
the toxic metabolites travel throughout
the body the effects of mycotoxins are
not always obvious to the naked eye
aflatoxin is well known as a potent
carcinogen and liver toxin as a
carcinogen it can enlarge the liver with
fatty material this can lead to
decreased pigment absorption which
causes the skin bleaching characteristic
of pale bird syndrome aflatoxin can
cause structural and functional damage
to other tissues including the heart and
kidneys the toxins also diminish immune
system response increasing
susceptibility to serious infection as
compared with healthy poultry and
affected Birds nutrient absorption and
metabolism are functionally compromised
reduced feed intake stunted growth poor
egg production and embryo viability
increased mortality and carcass
rejection lead to irreparable economic
loss proper feed and grain storage and
cleanliness are only one step in
preventing mycotoxins from affecting
your poultry Calabrian enteral sorbents
from Amla international are an essential
line of defence Calabrian a is uniquely
formulated and processed to rapidly
sequester mycotoxins this prevents
toxins from entering the blood here's
how it works
when the mycotoxin molecules enter the
stomach through contaminated feed they
are quickly absorbed by Caliburn
particles the porous structure of
Caliburn a and its specialized affinity
for the mycotoxin makes it the perfect
enter o servant when the bonded complex
moves through the small intestine the
mycotoxin stay bound preventing them
from being passed into the blood as a
result caliber and a reduces the
mycotoxin concentrations in the blood
helping to keep your poultry healthy and
productive the mycotoxin and enter o
sorbent are later excreted harmlessly
from your poultry Caliburn a enter o
sorbents are a powerful and necessary
barrier against my co toxicosis
you